here are the nominees for Best  Documentary Short subject in ascent day  Sean pine and Andrea Nix fine Kings  Point Sara Gilman and Jed wider Mondays  at Racine  Cynthia Wade and Robin Holman open heart  Keith Davidson and Corey Shepherd Stern  redemption Jon Alpert and Matthew  O'Neill  the first Academy Award  nomination for  they received their first nomination for  their film war data in the documentary  late and thank you so much for for this  we just want to think quickly our  amazing producer Alvey Hector went the  distance for this and Susan and yeah and  Ryan who's with us and all our like  artistic exploits and most of all we  want to thank you who was homeless just  a year ago and now she's standing in  front of all of you yeah and she's an  artist and all of you are artists and we  feel like we need to start supporting  arts they're dying in our communities  and all of us are artists and we need to  stand up and help girls like her be seen  and heard it's so important